- I'm obsessed with Disney.
- I'm very much a Disneyphile.
- I'm usually a Jasmine guy.
- Oh!
- Wait! Why are we here? What is this?
(laughter)
(whimsical music)
- So, we're gonna watch
three Disney scenes.
- Wait. Do we have to
recreate this or something?
- I already feel like I know what this is.
- This should be great.
Unless they throw in Lady and the Tramp.
Oh nooo!
- [Woman] It's the first one!
(laughter)
- [Both] There it is!
- Spaghetti kissin.
We knew it!
- [Man] Does that mean we
have to eat with...Oh no.
- He took bae out.
- Yeah he did.
- And he didn't even
have to pay for nothing.
- Obviously the lady. (laughs)
- Obviously you're the lady.
- How bad is this guy's restaurant doing
that he's got all this time
to just entertain these dogs?
- Oh, her eyes are twinkling!
- [Man] Twinkles!
- She is like DTF.
(laughter)
- So, at some point, I've gotta push
a meatball over with my nose.
- Witha the meat-ah-balls!
- Look cuter doing it, Ryan.
- It happens organically.
- Exactly!
(mumbles)
- That's too short.
We're not doin that one.
(laughing)
- [Man] Aw, you had it!
- This is ****.
(laughs)
(both laugh)
- Mmm, I got a little more spaghetti.
- Mmm, No!
I ****ed up!
- Uh oh, this is awkward!
Oh, it dropped.
(laughs)
(chair scoots away)
- (grunts) God, okay.
- I ate the whole meatball.
(laughs)
- Gettin major Beauty and the
Beast vibes from this set.
- Porridge. Oh!
- Oh no! (laughs)
- It's gruel. That's all
they ever ate was gruel.
(laughs)
- The ****?
- He was human at one point.
- Chip's kind of a little
***hole. He was just laughing.
- Relationship goals.
She's picking up the soup,
she's like: I'm gonna eat it like you.
- People pay a lot of
money for oatmeal facials.
- Ow! ***! It's hot!
(slobbery eating)
- This is good.
- It's a very inefficient way to eat.
- Then he wipes **** all over
his sleeves, like a gentleman.
- This tastes bad!
- This is some plain ass porridge.
- This sucks.
- [Girl in Hat] Whatever.
Is this how we use this?
- Oh, you poor (laughs)
- So now we have manners.
- Okay, ready?
- I know what this one is,
and I don't wanna do it.
- Lion King!
- Oh no!
They're gonna eat bugs!
- Tell me you did not think these bugs
looked juicy as hell
when you were younger?
- Oh God, they're so disgusting.
- [Man] Uhhh, it's so wiggly.
- The big, juicy bug.
- [Man] They actually look pretty good.
- No, they don't.
- [Both] Cream-filled.
- I don't like that.
- Ooh, that's a fat caterpillar.
- What the ***, dude. What the ***.
- [Woman] No **ing way.
- No, It can't be alive.
- Be careful?
- What?
- These are not live.
- I'm not taking it off.
- Ohh. (laughs)
- Not funny!
- It's gummy worms.
- Whoooo.
(laughs)
- You don't want a grub?
- Mine's stuck.
(slurps)
- Whoa, I got a big one.
- You don't look to be enjoying this part.
- Ah, the cream-filled kind!
- [Man] Yeah!
- Our situation hasn't improved here,
but she is giving it an A+ effort.
- This is so hard!
- I didn't like that one.
Ugh, Garrett!
- That was interesting. I
did not expect any of that.
- It's a silly, fun way to
have a snack with a friend.
- How the creators were like: you know,
I think he just, doesn't
even use spoons and ****.
- Turns out, you never notice how crazy
they eat things in Disney movies.
- Our skin feels nice and
clean from the oatmeal.
- See, that's what Belle
fell for: great skin.
- Now I just wish that Peter
Pan food could come to life.
(wiping whoosh)
(creaking sign)